This question is about both gravity and electricity.
Let's say that Benjamin Franklin is standing in a room holding an object.
This room actually has a horizontal electric field.
That electric field is equal to 100 N/C.
Obviously, Ben Franklin is very excited, because he gets to do an experiment with electricity.
Furthermore, let's say that this ball has both a mass, 8 kg,
and it's actually charged as well.
It's charge is 0.1 C. That's a positive charge.
Now what's going to happen when he releases this ball is it will feel two forces.
It will, of course, feel a force from gravity downward,
but it's also going to feel an electric force.
It's going to undergo 2-dimensional motion,
but this will be much different than the 2-dimensional motion of a ball being thrown
in the air under normal circumstances,
because now there's going to be a horizontal component of acceleration.
I want you to tell me if this height is equal to 1.2 m
and we know that the ball will feel a force over here
so it'll probably land somewhere--I don't know--here or here or here.
I want you to tell me d--the distance away from Ben Franklin
where the ball strikes the ground.
You can enter your answer here in meters.
I'm warning you this is quite a tricky question,
but using what you know about F = ma and motion and electricity
you can tie it all together, and I believe you can get this answer. Give it a shot.